الهجوم الايرانيه الاخيره على بلدتك
وسنجاق لم يكن
الاول وعلى الارجاح لن يكون الاخير وبينما
مرت بغداد بسنوات من الضعف الحكوميه وبين
التنازع بين اربيل وغياب العنصر الامني عن
حدود ايران مع الاقليم المتضرر الوحيد هو
العراق كل هذه العوامل اجتمعت اما دعم او
تبرير من جبهات او جهات الداخليه لتتيح
لايران التدخل والتهديد باستهداف في مناطق
مقتضى بالمدنيين الحرس الثوري كشف تواجده
على الحدود وهذه كفف التواجد على الحدود
وهذه الاحداث تنبي
عفوا ابي امر اخر خطير ان ايران على خطى
تركيا عبر تنفيذ عمليه عسكريه داخل حدود
اقليم كردستان في حال بقيت الاحزاب
الكرديه الايرانيه المعارضه على الحدود
مجموعه من الازمات تعقد المشهد امام حكومه
السودان اربيل اثار في ضوء اشراك الحكومه
الاتحاديه في ملفات الاقليم او نشر قواتا
اتحاديه او على حدود مع ايران ورغم
التهديد ابي اجراءاتنا من حكومه السودانيه
لا شيئا نفذ ولا انتهاكات وقفت وهو ما فتح
الباب امام طهران لتوظيفهاماتها لاهدافا
سياسيه الاكراد المسلحون هم السبب في
تاجيج الاحتجاجات الايرانيه وهكذا ترى
السلطات في ايران
امرنا جعلها تواصل والهامات وتؤكد
واستمرارها والسبيل الوحيد لايقافها هو
وقف الاحتجاجات الداخليه
كيف بالضبط على الحسبين الكرديين الحاكمين
في الاقليم بهدف التاثير على اكراد ايران
ومطالبتهم بتهدئه الاحتجاجات من مصدر
شرارتها من المدن الكرديه وربما لذلك لجات
زياره جاءت الزيرتان قاني لبغداد ولقاء
السوداني ورئيس العراق لاقليم كردستان